can I ask a question if you can't get
these across state lines how did you do
it
I took a quick road trip from New York
to Montreal this weekend in the pouring
rain I brought back a few items that you
just can't find stateside just some my
co-workers can triumph they better like
them not for resale in the United States
damn here you go those they're gonna be
like a prize when we open it up we're
gonna choke on camera okay I don't know
what this is about
oh so I don't understand how people are
getting injured when it's literally in
another egg I'm trying to go for like a
child right ready go
okay like I bit the thing and I couldn't
bite any farther like there are no more
biting things what boy there's like
accessible the toy is not the egg
what is this chapstick your son that
would be nice though oh my let's go
check we have plenty of toys like this
in America that kids joke because it's
coming in the chocolate they're like
this whole thing that must be something
that I can eat right now like do
Canadian kids not choke on plastic and
choke on these things like why can they
have it we can I think it's a medium
kids this might be smart
[Music]
Oh smells like oh my god is this it's
not like licorice this is awesome oh
[Music]
it's like oh my god it tastes like
fireball at first and then it just goes
to straight burning and then it goes
back to like jägerbomb please drink with
extreme caution
isn't this the stuff that uh Shakespeare
used to do songs for this I'm okay with
that being banned don't bring this [ __ ]
over here keep this fixed in Ontario
Montreal Holly this is Canada is known
universally as the nicest country so why
would there be things that Canada allows
that other places don't allow free
health care I don't know absent I think
Canada is trying to give us a little
time out there like look you wiling down
there down south so we got these good
things over here you can't get none
sorry but that's what happens when
you're in timeout
Wow
[Music]